[Musique]
et selon moi et les journalistes capter
secret story l'émission d'albert pour
moi le boss de l'année ce serait
jonathan et je vais y attend
[Musique]
pour moi le plus beau moment de l'année
ce serait pas au moment des auteurs mais
c'est un très bon souvenir
la dame blanche avec akon
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir dans quelques mps
serait la venue de la route le meilleur
chroniqueur de l'année ce serait minime
de rhétorique c'est une bonne ce jour le
sourire à la tête
j'en suis pas fier et je me demande
pourquoi j'ai gelé confier ça à la prod
aujourd'hui mon conseil ce sera pour
maximiser ni de moins à prendre sa fiche
et il serait bien plus productif at il
eu une relation relations